It was completely predictable that Republican
Senator Ted Cruz's approval rating was going
to fall among Democrats and among left leaning
independents after he in a completely I mean,
I don't know what he was thinking, but he well,
actually, I do know what he was thinking. He
fled with his family to Cancun when the power
went out in his home state of Texas. And what
he was thinking was quite clear, which is, I
want to have power. Let's go somewhere where
it's warm and there's power. That's exactly what
he was thinking until it completely blew up in his
face. And so we were expecting that is already
low approval among Democrats and left leaning
independents was going to fall. But Ted Cruz's
approval rating has collapsed 20 points among
Republican voters. And this is really a
signal of the worst situation for Ted Cruz
since he took office in 2013. Quite frankly,
according to a Yahoo! YouGov poll, 24 percent
of voters approve of him overall and 49 percent
disapprove. That's a net approval of minus 25 for
Ted Cruz. But that's overall. And when you look at
the Republican numbers in a morning consult poll,
Ted Cruz is at 53 percent approval among
Republicans. That's down 23 points from
January on January 9th. After the Trump riots,
76 percent of Republicans supported Ted Cruz.
And that number is now down 23 points to 53
percent Republican support for Ted Cruz. Nearly
half of the Republican Party does not
approve of Ted Cruz. And that is absolutely
stunning. Ted Cruz's approval was already sort
of on the decline in January. If you go back
to December, you see that in the period from
December 27 to January five, Cruz's approval
was 81 percent among Republicans. Then January
six to nine, the immediate aftermath of the riot,
he was down from 81 to 76 percent approval among
Republicans and then now 53 percent approval among
Republicans. Now, for us, the unfortunate reality,
and it's been a reality that's much bigger than
Ted Cruz for a long time. Ted Cruz isn't up for
reelection until twenty twenty four. He just won
in twenty eighteen six year terms for senators,
up again in twenty twenty four. That's an insanely
long amount of time for this to have any effect
electorally. I know that we can hope that voters
will remember this in twenty twenty four. I
think it's just too long. The circumstances
in twenty, twenty four for Ted Cruz are going
to be far more dictated by what's going on
at the time. Is Trump the Republican nominee or
not. Other factors at that point and if this were
to have an effect, it would be getting Ted Cruz
to resign. Now, there seems to be no chance that
that happens. I've seen no indication whatsoever,
no reason to think Ted Cruz is going to resign
over this the way out. Of Ted Cruz as a senator in
Texas is to register new voters and to get out the
vote, it's not to convert existing Republican
voters. What we've learned many times is that
if you rely on Republican voters to remember the
horrible things that their elected officials did.
You don't win, it's just not a winning
strategy, is what we've learned over time.
Ted Cruz will have a bounce back. He has now
four years to start getting on all of the
tired trope. So we've got to fight socialism.
And the debt is, you know, all that stuff.
He'll have a bounce back. There will be some,
you know, tragedy of some kind that will allow
him to talk about how the left wants to take your
guns. And if he wants to be reelected, he almost
certainly will. If we leave it to Republicans in
Texas to decide and remember the things he did,
the way to defeat Ted Cruz is to get out
the vote and to register new voters. And if
this reelection campaign for Cruz were maybe in
twenty twenty two, there'd be more of a shot at
the Cancun fiasco, having an impact. If it were
twenty, twenty one, it would be even better.
But the cautious optimism for twenty twenty four
is that Cruz did only defeat Beto O'Rourke by
a small margin, about fifty one to forty eight in
twenty eighteen. If the election were now or in a
few months and we were hammering, hammering,
hammering on get out the vote and registering
voters, I think that overall would have a real
shot at defeating Ted Cruz four years from now
makes it more difficult to predict. But let's
prove ourselves wrong. If Ted Cruz is going
to be defeated on twenty twenty four, it will
be because of the campaign that we mount. Then
we saw the model in Georgia with Stacey Abrams
and registering new new voters, Joe Biden winning
Georgia, two Democratic challengers in the Senate
in Georgia, defeating two Republican incumbents
in Georgia so it can be done. We've seen the
playbook simply waiting for the Cancun fiasco to
effect Republicans four years from now. That's
not the winning strategy. I'm open to having
my mind changed, but I've seen no evidence
that that's the way to win that seat back.